every cell in our body when it's happy
or safe it expands and moves toward and
that's like the feeling of having a
crush on someone or when someone's like
let's go out to Sushi and you're like
yes and every cell when it's unsafe it
contracts and moves away and
that's uh what you feel when somebody
puts food in front of you that you're
allergic to or have had food poisoning
or something you know that feeling of
like I just won't eat that and she said
I want you to start thinking about your
life in terms of are these decisions
expansive or contractive to me or now I
think about it as do I have a crush on
this decision and once I started doing
that it made decisions a lot easier for
me and I started to actually evolve
without overthinking the decisions I was
making and doing things that like were
surprising to me which has been very
very useful